make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so normally we would post a video
on the boys today but because the fact
of the Black Widow trailer dropped I
thought we'd do a video explaining read
Guardian because a lot of people are
kind of curious about him here's a funny
thing about Red Guardian being
introduced in the MCU this is the first
thing I thought when he popped up I was
like okay so why are we gonna introduce
a character who basically had like a
two-part story arc and then died and
then came back as a life model decoy
like why would they introduce him I
would say it's not really because of Red
Guardian I mean he's there as a plot
device I would say the bigger thing here
is that it can lead to the introduction
of Colossus in the x-men in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and so what we'll get
to that here in a little bit but for red
guardian himself he debuted back in
Avengers issue number 43 in 1967 and he
was created by Roy Thomas now a little
bit of history here white Thomas was
kind of like the next big writer after
Stanley and the reason for that is
because while Stan Lee and Jack Kirby
are in a lot of ways consider to be the
kind of one-two punch of comic books and
so far as a lot of the work the two of
them put in including a Steve Ditko in
the early days of Marvel introducing
like Thor and Iron Man spider-man
returning Captain America to the
landscape of course he was originally
created by a Jack Kirby and Joe Simon
bringing in a lot of these major heroes
here characters like that Natasha
Romanoff like Black Widow while she was
created by Stan Lee and Don heck it was
one of these things where it was coming
at a point where Stan Lee was being
removed as a position of just a standard
writer and being promoted to editor in
chief and so because that when it came
to him basically leaving the writing
duties somebody else had to take over
and for the most part you had Boyd
Thomas who had really burned his bones
you know as part of the old Charlton
comics him back in the day which
ultimately a lot of those characters
like Blue Beetle from the Charlton
comics were taken over by DC and rolled
into their lineup but he basically made
his bones as a writer who knew what he
was doing and so when he came on board
he basically became the new Stan Lee
insofar as he was writing pretty much
everything in Marvel at the time in some
form or another there really hasn't been
a title outside of maybe spider-man that
Roy Thomas is not either written or had
some kind of involvement in crafting
regarding the various stories that
existed really between the late 1960s
going into the the early to mid 1970s
and the 1980s and so with that being the
case when Thomas came on as Stanley left
Thomas basically looked at like the
entire landscape of Marvel as it existed
and said okay here's one of the biggest
issues that we have here is you've got a
lot of plot threads that have been left
hanging
especially with characters like Black
Widow Natasha Romanoff appeared back in
tales of suspense number 52 of course
she was created by Stan Lee and
but for the most part nobody knew
anything about her and so the idea was
to basically flesh out her backstory if
only just a little bit test the waters
and see how people responded and so the
best way to do that was not simply just
introduce a character and call it a day
it was introduce a character drive
interest and see if see if people
responded accordingly and so red
guarding was basically brought in as
this guy named Alexi who is essentially
the Russian government's response to
Captain America and the Avengers and the
reason for this was because in the
aftermath of World War 2 much like the
real world it turned into like this kind
of Cold War right where you basically
had the United States and Russia
engaging in a Cold War because they
never actually fought with each other
instead it was a series of proxy
conflict why for those are guys who are
familiar with this when it came to the
Cold War right like like you know kind
of deviating away from comics for a
second and talking about the real world
when it came to the Cold War it was like
the soviet-afghan war of the 1980s the
Korean War the the Vietnam War these
were conflicts whereby the United States
and Russia were kind of engaging in a
war of sorts to try to spread their own
spheres of influence right so the United
States and capitalism versus Russia and
communism and so he ended up seeing like
these kind of small conflicts and the
comics it was designed to reflect that
right because back during 1960s and 70s
comics reflected the real world of
course when franklin richards was born
all that stopped and that's the reason
why you see a lot of people getting
credence to the idea that franklin
richards controls the Marvel Universe
because once his character was
introduced it coincided with Marvel
introducing the idea that they would
never actually reflect the real world
instead they would try to make their
comics comics timeless by never actually
telling you when events take place and
so because of that what you ended up
getting was was the Russian government
sitting down and saying well if the
United States has the Avengers and
Captain America then we need something
comparable and so alexei who was a
decorated pilot and married to natasha
romanoff at the time I was basically
taken by it by the Russian KGB ah and
then he in turn was inducted into the
Red Guardian program as its second
iteration Natasha Romanoff was told her
husband died as the result of that is it
allowed for Thomas to kind of focus on
her character and basically bring her
closer and eventually join the The
Avengers as well as rescuing Wolverine
and eventually starting a relationship
or a romantic relationship with Hawkeye
and so following this this led into
really kind of a bit of a crossover not
a massive one but a bit of a crossover
insofar as that it involved really
Avengers issue number 41 as well as Roy
Thomas's final issue on strange tales
with issue number 159 that involves
shield basically discovering the fact
that the Chinese government hadn't
to use a device called the psychotron
which could induce mass hallucinations
and then in turn use that as a means to
either dominate the world or to corrupt
the superheroes whatever the case wanted
to be and so in turn they dispatched
natasha romanoff esta you know to be
basically be a spy for the Russian
government to essentially monitor what
it was a China was doing at the same
time the offenders were dispatched as
well in order to deal with the threat
and then of course read Guardian as part
of the Russian government was sent to to
intervene and to see what it was what
the potential was in terms of practical
applications for the psychotron if it
was taken by the Russian government and
used for their own ends and so over the
course of of strange tales 159 and an
Avengers issues 41 42 43 and 44 you
basically had this story play out where
by the Tasha Romanoff learned her
husband was alive albeit in a far more
ruthless state insofar as the KGB
training had basically kind of
brainwashed him to a degree and so his
only real desire was to demonstrate that
he was better than Captain America and
then at the same time having him face
off against Captain America temporarily
now the battle between Red Guardian and
cap was pretty short-lived insofar as
ended up happening was Colonel Ling who
was the one that was overseeing the
psychotron project intended to kill
Captain America and so red Guardian
intervened because he deemed it to be a
cowardly thing which fell in line
somewhat with the with the Russian
ideology of strength and this basically
led to red Guardian sacrificing his life
or at least believing to have sacrificed
his life along with killing general Ling
and then ultimately Captain America the
Avengers and Black Widow escaping but
following this there were a couple of
attempts by Marvel over the years to
kind of reinvigorate interest in the red
Guardian concept now there was a guy
named Joseph PICUs who basically became
the new red Guardian as part of the
winter guard but in terms of just Alexei
himself there were a couple instances
where he showed up as a life model decoy
which is to say basically a robot that
looks walks and talks exactly like the
original version right so in Marvel
Comics so those guys who don't know in
model Comics life model decoys well
really they're most commonly used by
Anik fury but life model decoys are
exceedingly capable and in fact not even
really Wolverine can tell the difference
between a life model decoy and a regular
person depending on who's writing the
story sometimes you can it really just
kind of fluctuates and bounces around
based on on what they're doing but again
like for alexei he kind of popped up
here and there and not a whole lot came
of it in daredevil volume 2 issue number
64 in 2004 by brian michael bendis there
was a story that involved the return of
alexei ultimately he was captured but he
was basically this whole great big huge
scenario where he you know set up as
this crazy situation that led to him in
and BlackWidow being reunited or at
least Black Widow being aware of the
fact that he was alive I don't really
think any explanation was given in terms
of how he lived ah but ultimately he was
there and then eventually taken into
custody he did become the newest
iteration of Ronin but nothing really
came out of Alexi after the little
miniseries by Roy Thomas he was just
kind of a guy who's there and so again
sort of getting into this discussion
about the idea of why he's even in the
MCU in the first place under normal
circumstances I mean most likely hope
you care to he'll die there's really no
reason to keep him there there specially
because of the fact the way he's
depicted he's aging he's he's fat uh he
really can't be a comparable hero in any
real means likely he'll die in a die in
the film but what's important is what
can come out of the red Guardian and so
the idea behind this and this is a man
important to bear in mind is that in
Russia what you had was a team called
the winter guard and the winter guard
was basically Russia's attempt to create
her own version of The Avengers now
eventually characters like Crimson
Dynamo would go on to join the de winter
guard but before it was officially
formed Russia basically started
traveling around their own country and
grabbing various individuals who had
powers that could that could be
brainwashed or co-opted into the winter
guard program and then forced to fight
on behalf of the Russian government one
of the individuals who was attempted to
wear I guess whose capture was attempted
by the Russians was Colossus and the
idea was that at the time Charles Xavier
had basically he was in the process of
forming a new x-men team in response to
the capture of the original x-men by the
mutant island of kokoa
and so traveling to various iterations
with giant-size x-men number one it was
really just away from Marvel to
introduce a more diverse x-men team but
traveling around to different locations
going to Africa a recruiting storm going
to Japan recruiting Sunfire the he ended
up traveling to Russia and actually
arrived at the home of Colossus right at
the time when he was being cornered and
confronted by Russian agents who were
ultimately going to kidnap him and then
kind of brainwashing in the KGB program
and ultimately lead to him becoming at
least you know whatever role he was
going to take on the winter guard Xavier
intercepted and then basically saved the
life of Colossus and then in turn asked
him to join the x-men which Colossus did
but that's the reason why this is so
important is because I wouldn't really
say that Red Guardian is significant and
of himself he's just a character who's
there I mean what really matters and
what really comes out of this is what
Marvel can do what the Marvel Cinematic
Universe can do with their own iteration
of that right like introduced in the
winter guard introducing the idea of
like you know expanding on black widows
own story right because black widow and
really like her father works with
Wolverine for time Black Widow was
trained in various ways by the Winter
Soldier although given the
given the movie Captain America the
Winter Soldier it doesn't really look
like the the two of them have had any
real history together outside of the
fact that he shot her at one point in
time but I would say the biggest thing
about this is that this could
essentially set the stage for small
introductions here and there right like
you basically got a post-credits scene
where Russia is like okay so like the
Red Guardian died but like we should
reboot the program right because like
there's no more Captain America in the
United States no more Steve Rogers
you've got Sam Wilson Way doesn't really
have any powers so let's create our own
version of Captain America like what are
we gonna call the team we're gonna call
them the wear guard go forward and
capture people and the first thing they
do is they show up on the on the
doorstep of Colossus and the camera pans
away to a mailbox it says like Rasputin
or something like that you know whatever
the case is you know there's a lot of
things that can really come out of this
but for Alexei himself for the red
Guardian he's by no means a significant
character he's not going to change the
landscape of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the game doesn't shift because
he's in this movie now uh it's just kind
of a character who's there who never had
any real significance in Marvel Comics
and really kind of begs the question for
those of us who were familiar with
Marvel why is he even in the movie in
the first place but again you know I say
it's just setting the stage for much
bigger things to come later on down the
line but I know this is a much shorter
video than we normally do with with the
the explained series but you're talking
about a character who appeared in like
two issues so that's really all there is
to it but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here two comments explain
and make sure you guys with the sub
button to become part of the rob4 if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]